(wine pouring)
- I wanna sing a little ditty
for my sweet, very short friend, Rebecca,
who is turning 22 tomorrow,
wink, wink!
(laughing)
I'm gonna give you something
you ain't never had before.
- Yes!
(gentle piano music)
- Close your eyes ...
- [Crowd] Oh!
- I'm cool.
- Yay!
- It's an amazing day in wine country.
- When was the last time
we were all together?
- [Rebecca] I just want this
to feel like a regular vacation,
and somewhere in there
I'll just slide into 50.
- [All] To Rebecca!
- Age is just a number.
What would you say your soul's age is?
- Eighteen.
Old enough to drink and bone.
Don't have my own car yet,
but I have a bike.
(bell ringing)
- I made itineraries of
everything we're gonna do
minute by minute on the trip.
We have lavender popping corn.
- That's not enough.
- Oh my god.
- We wanna keep this party goin'!
- [Rebecca] What is that?
- Molly.
(gasps)
- I did Molly in college,
but she went back to her boyfriend.
- Ayo!
- Celebrating with a girls weekend, huh?
Just remember guys, whatever gets said,
it's probably what the
person has always felt,
and the alcohol just let it out.
(wine pouring)
(gentle piano music)
- This weekend is a mess.
(screaming)
- Something bit me!
- Oh my God, I'm gonna die!
- I can't even plan a fun birthday trip.
- If you were just to let go,
everything will just fall into place.
- Will it fall into place?
(screams)
- Do you think throwing the
itineraries out the window
was on the itinerary?
- Guess we'll never know.
♪ Close your eyes, give
me your hand, darling. ♪
- If we can't get through
a weekend together,
then I'm completely lost.
- [All] Do you understand?
- Just get to the bush and
you're fine from there!
That's what she said.
- These women, I have
known for 20 plus years.
And yeah, sometimes I wanna
tell this one to fuck off.
- You want me to fuck off?
- That's what intimacy looks like.
- [All] Day!
- This one's good, what's it called again?
- White wine.
- Ugh, freakin' love it!